the European Parliament has voted to
remove one of its vice presidents from
office
Ava Kylie is being held in jail on
corruption chart is linked to the Gulf
State of Qatar she's denied the
allegations through her lawyer the
Scandal threatens to undermine the
parliament's ongoing corruption
investigations into several EU member
states though she's lost her role as a
parliamentary vice president the Greek
socialist Kylie remains A Member of
Parliament which is one of six people
arrested by Belgian police as part of an
anti-corruption investigation two of
them have been released from custody
after questioning Parliament The House
of the European democracy all the
parliament said president Rebecca
metzola says the corruption Scandal
could go even further
whether it is tightening of our rules
whether it is inquiring further whether
it is looking at the influence of
certain third countries
we will not stop and leave leave no
stone unturned I cannot predict where
this will go but what I can say I fear
and this isn't a general point of view
after our initial findings is that the
story will not stop here
all right let's join our correspondent
Barbara vasel at the EU Parliament
building in Strasbourg a welcome Barbara
So this very much sounds like we're at
the start of a process that the
parliament is going to find very
uncomfortable
definitely so I mean this is just the
beginning of the horrors that are yet to
follow
um you just have to imagine Phil that
the battery police had wire TAPS in
place for a while on some of those
suspects and we don't really know yet
what is going to emerge from those uh
some sort of tasty details have been in
the Belgian press for instance say the
wife of one of the suspects talking
about a hundred thousand Euro holiday
that they had last year and this year
they would have to be a bit more modest
now those are the things that are really
noxious for the European Parliament
because people citizens who are
hard-pressed in these times of inflation
they will look at this and say what are
they doing there this is disgusting they
are corrupt and it is really something
that sort of throws the light on the
whole Parliament on not only on the
people who are really actively engaged
in that corruption right so Ava Kaylee
has now lost her role her job as a as a
vice president of the parliament she
clearly has questions to answer but it
does sound as though she's being
punished before she's she's actually
been found guilty
yeah but she's still in police detention
so that means that a Belgium judge judge
must after checking out the facts and
the evidence be convinced that she is
guilty enough to be further investigated
and maybe go to court so that in a case
in a way is enough for the European
Parliament and there was so much anger
here and frustration of parliamentarians
that they was with almost unanimously
voted against her and to kick her out of
her office today because people just
feel they don't want to be drawn into
this they want to distance themselves
from her and so the presumption of
innocence has ended on the weekend I'm
afraid when the police took her in what
will emerge on the on the judicial side
from this of course we don't know yet
but politically the Socialist the Greek
socialist still parliamentarian is
absolutely finished right so lots of
people are throwing their hands up in
horror and saying this is terrible but
we we have the discovery of alleged
corruption followed by arrest the
promise of further investigations and
reforms you could look at this and say
well this is not a disaster this is
proof that the system works
the system hasn't worked but because the
system of the parliament hasn't worked
to figure this out much earlier because
this has been going on for months I mean
this has been going on last year as far
as we know so this is a longer standing
Scandal this has just evolved over time
and uh a lot of money has been handed
over we're at a cool million at the
moment we don't know yet whether they're
going to be secret bank accounts and
other stuff to be found so no the system
of parliament to prevent this has not
worked at all they didn't figure it out
even though there were suspicions
against Eva Kylie because she was so
incredibly pro-cutter but nobody even
thought that she would be taking money
for her services so what has worked is
the Belgium police and and the Belgium
justice system and that certainly for
Parliament cannot be good enough thank
you for that Barbara Barbara basil in
strasbour